[Applause]
this border situation is completely
completely insane I want to start with
this video that every single American
should have seen this video this should
have been the lead on every 6:30 NBC CBS
uh ABC news program and everything else
every cable news program but of course
it was not check out what is going on at
the Texas border this is in El Paso this
is I think two days
[Applause]
ago
absolutely insane absolutely insane
there are many other videos like that we
are being told the border is secure
we've been gaslit for the last two years
with this Administration Sarah you're in
Texas I know this one's personal to you
go ahead yeah I mean what you're seeing
right there is how a republic crumbles
it it is mindboggling to me that this
Administration is so so toned deaf that
they think that this could end any way
other than complete destruction of the
entire country uh you know this is why
you see people like um you know mayor
Eric Adams you see Kathy hokel you see
uh you know leaders in Chicago you see
all of these blue cities blue States who
previously were like oh well we're just
Sanctuary cities because we just care
about immigrants we we want to bring
them bring the masses and they're
finding out oh wait a second we don't
have the economic resources to sustain
this which is the entire point and so
you know I watch this stuff and and I'm
thinking obviously I'm going to vote for
whoever the Republican candidate is sign
me up I'll crawl over broken glass to
vote for them to but but but but I I
don't think that I can take any
Republican seriously who does not say
this cannot end in any way other than
sure secure the Border we got to do that
but we have to talk about Mass
deportations I know it's a very
difficult thing for Republican
candidates to talk about I think it
feels very icky for them to actually say
the words out loud but you look at that
amount of people just in that one video
now multiply that by the millions and
millions and millions of people just who
have come in in the last two and a half
years what is that going to look like 10
years down the line for this country
they're taking over New York hotels that
I mean we're hearing all sorts of of
stories about what a drain they are
financially just wait until you multiply
that in 10 years where does that lead we
have to get these people out of the
country and I think that rep repan
candidates and just candidates overall
really need to start talking about a a
two or three or four pronged approach
sure secure the Border but we've got to
get these people who are coming in we
have got to remove
them